Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
thor loving thunder movie review we're firmly
in marvel phase 4 chris hemsworth one of the
few marvel phase one original avengers actors
who can now say he's gotten a fourth sequel to
his spin-off movies not counting all those big
avengers crossover movies they do together so if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing an imax ticket
giveaway for the movie all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just post your favorite
thor moment on the video and since i'm posting
this before the movies come out everywhere please
don't post really big spoilers in the comments
don't worry i will release my post credit
scene video full easter eggs breakdown videos
bonus videos for the rest of the really specific
things in the movie later this week after it
comes out because there is a lot of really big
really cool stuff that we have to talk about
but just starting with the biggest thing probably
the biggest thor in the room is that this movie is
very much the brainchild of taika watiti there's
all kinds of jokes now about how when you listen
to kevin feige and taika both talk about the
making the movie kevin feige sounds kind of like
tyka's dad like taika waititi is this little kid
running around they given all this power to and
he's just trying to create this movie out of the
most crazy things that just pop out of his brain
like what is the craziest thing i could possibly
do with a thor character with these marvel movies
so thor ragnarok was like a huge left turn
for the franchise when he came on board like
we joke about it being the first movie in a new
thor trilogy because it's so different from the
first two thor films you almost consider it like
a soft reboot of the character in the franchise
you have to imagine when they were making that
movie taika watiti was very conservative because
he was brand new on the lot like very first marvel
movie so he was a little more conservative in his
creative choices and what they did with the
movie just in general but because ragnarok
utterly crushed the box office of the first two
thor films it was so successful it just feels like
that empowered him and marvel and kevin feige just
let him do whatever he wanted to do with thor love
and thunder like taika watiti was like okay gloves
come off i'm gonna make this movie as huge and
crazy as possible i would say the trailers have
been pretty honest about the tone and the vibe of
what's going on during the movie sometimes marvel
trailers can be kind of misleading about the tone
and just what's going on during the movie in
general like they try to be very misleading with
the spiderman no way home trailers but everything
you see in the thor love and thunder trailers is
pretty true to the tone and the feel of the movie
just in general so in that sense love and thunder
is very much a taika watiti movie so it's like
super ragged rock in a creative sense so if you
like what taiko batidi did with thor ragnarok and
the characters you'll probably love thor love and
thunder like it gives you thor ragnarok times
a hundred but if you didn't like what ty got
what td did with thor ragnarok or with the thor
character you're probably not gonna like thor
love and thunder quite as much one of my favorite
aspects of the movie though is all the deep cosmic
mythology that it gets into it's like a mixture
of the gore storyline from the comics which itself
was really cool i would definitely recommend going
out and reading that gore storyline if you haven't
read those comics yet the mighty thor jane foster
arc where she became a version of thor which is a
completely different storyline in the comics done
in the tone of something like big trouble little
china like big trouble little asgard there's even
a point in the trailers where you hear thor say ah
another classic thor adventure like that's the
tone of the movie basically ragnarok was very
80s inspired thor love and thunder as you can
see from the trailers is also very 80s inspired
mixed with a lot of really cool cosmic concepts
and super op characters and deep cuts that don't
really fit in like the lower earth based ground
level movies in series like this is all stuff in
the trailer so i don't think it's a spoiler to say
like they're not going to talk about the watcher
the cosmic entity death on hawkeye and because
thor is a real god in the mcu because of the
nature of the gore storyline they use the movie to
explain how gods exist in the mcu and do more with
the mcu guys just in general than you've seen in
previous marvel movies and series like moonite for
example and they've kind of addressed his role
as a god in the mcu during previous thor movies
but this movie really goes there like you really
learn how the other gods exist and there are many
gods in the mcu it's even more cosmic than like
doctor strange 2 which featured a character like
the living tribunal so if you really like
those cosmic characters those concepts from
stuff like the thanos infinity gauntlet comics
like the ultimates comics where you see the most
powerful most abstract characters to ever cross
the page in marvel this movie gets into that in
spades it is barely a two-hour movie so one
of my few complaints is that it feels kind of
like a speed run version of all that like wait a
minute they're all these big cosmic concepts all
these really cool things that you're introducing
in the movie spend more time on that hopefully
they'll use other marvel movies and marvel series
to get into that in a bigger way i'll address
this in a second but i think one of the reasons
why the movie is so short and feels like such a
speed run is because they wanted it to feel very
self-contained compared to a movie say like doctor
strange 2 which had so many different things so
many different ideas going on during the film
chris hemsworth was greatest or he's been playing
the character for so long he could do it in his
sleep and just like the movie is metaphorically
bigger than any thor movie that's come before
chris hemsworth himself has found a way to become
literally bigger in buffer than he has ever been
in any marvel movie before seriously it seems like
he gets bigger every time a new marvel movie comes
and like we told all the jokes about thor
gaining all that weight during avengers end game
the movie does spend some time early in the film
with a funny 80s style inspired workout montage
explaining how he lost the weight like okay yeah
we've done that we're not going to do that again
but let's turn it into a funny thing about how he
gets swole again you all remember thor ragnarok
obviously he does a great job of playing that
big dumb animal version of thor like he almost
can't be heard physically so they just use him a
lot for comedy in situations like that but he's
also gotten way better at doing the dramatic more
emotional thor stuff as well and there is a lot of
that during the movie too like the entire movie
isn't just wall-to-wall jokes like it does turn
on a dime to really emotional stuff during periods
natalie portman was also really good at balancing
those different aspects of the characters in
the film out like you think of her as a more
dramatic actress to begin with but it's almost
like tycho batidi took her character jane foster
and ragnarocked her like okay we're just
gonna completely reimagine you and do a
different version of your character that's gonna
be way better than the version that we did in the
previous marvel movies so even though on a story
level there's a lot of different things going on
with our character just creatively in general she
feels kind of like a soft reboot of the character
she also did a good job with the funny meat head
thor related comedy in the film like she obviously
becomes a version of thor you've seen in all the
trailers along with that comes a lot of the thor
specific comedy that you see from characters that
are that big and that powerful and christian bale
you can't say enough about that dude he's amazing
in everything that he does so there was no doubt
that he was going to be amazing in this movie
everyone was just wondering what gore was going
to look like and what they were going to do with
his story from the comics because the gore story
line is such a cool story line they did make some
creative changes to gore's look most people will
be talking about the way taka watiti explained
that is that they changed his face to make it
look a little bit more human because he wanted to
avoid the obvious comparison that a lot of casual
fans would make to voldemort they also did change
gore's storyline a little bit from the comics just
to fit with what they've already done in the mcu
so everything just makes sense on a cosmic level
and remember it is a two hour movie so it's like
a speed run version of gore's storyline from the
comics they've been hyping him up as one of the
best characterizations of a villain in marvel that
they've ever done i do agree that he's probably
one of the better villain story lines that
marvel's ever done next to loki and thanos not
only because christian bale's so fantastic he's so
great at performing the character but also because
you understand where he's coming from in the same
way that you understood where thanos was coming
from like there's all the memes thanos was right
that was actually a huge plot twist in the comics
as well in a completely different later storyline
where they literally do the line gore was right
so you'll probably come out of this movie saying
gore was right like that'll be one of the next
big memes so for example just talking about thor's
specific characters if malakith in thor the dark
world was one of their weakest villains ever in
a marvel movie christian bale is probably like
the exact opposite of that and like i said even
though the movie is super short for a marvel movie
the guardians of the galaxy were all great james
gunn did get to overseed some of the dialogue and
created their scenes during the movie any time
they use the guardians and other big scenes like
when they used him during avengers infinity war
and avengers end game james gunn got to oversee
their parts of the film they were all fantastic
they were only in the movie for a little bit but
they were an important part of the film and like
i said i think that's because they wanted this to
feel like a smaller self-contained thor story like
if you put the guardians in there for the entire
movie then it turns into something completely
different and even though there are a lot of
things that happen in it there are a lot of cosmic
ramifications going forward in marvel phase four
a lot of cosmic consequences the story is very
much self-contained to the thor character kind
of in the same way that the black panther movie
was self-contained relative to what you think
from other marvel phase 1 phase 2 movies that
were much more interconnected so if you didn't
like doctor strange 2 because there were so many
different story lines and things and characters
going on in that movie so many big left turns
with the new characters you'll probably enjoy thor
love and thunder more just because it focuses more
on the core characters and because the movie is so
heavily inspired visually creatively from the 80s
the score is very 80s inspired the movie probably
has some of the best music of any marvel movie so
far that includes the original sound score they
created for the movie and also the real 80s songs
like the pop songs that they licensed for the
movie like real good example of that is ronnie
james dio's rainbow in the dark the funny thing
is is that tycho batidi told us years ago what the
tone the vibe of the film was going to be some of
the music when they announced the movie at marvel
comic con 2019 that's how long ago it was 2019 the
actors came on stage to ronnie james dio's rainbow
in the dark and without giving away spoilers or
anything that song is in the movie but you have
to imagine the entire movie is that vibe that tone
that type of music one of my few complaints about
the movie though was some of the cinematography
and you'll probably see this complaint
in common from a lot of different people there's
a significant chunk of the movie that was filmed
on those new led wall sound stages like the same
tech that they used to film the mandalorian series
where instead of building everything practically
they just generate it digitally on led walls and
it becomes very obvious in some scenes like it
seems like a downgrade in some scenes almost maybe
they'll polish that in the next few weeks because
marvel does do this they are known to release
movies before everything is completely finished so
if you went to see avengers end game for instance
opening weekend and then you saw it again a couple
weeks later the second version that you saw a
couple weeks later would have even better looking
cgi so marvel continues to re-release and polish
versions of movies while they're still in theaters
so i think it'll be a similar case with thor
11 thunder we'll have to compare to the other
upcoming marvel movies like black panther 2 and
ant-man 3 quantum mania with king the conqueror
that use some of similar led wall technology to
film their big scenes to see if they do a better
job over time because i think part of it is also
marvel just getting used to using those creatively
in the making of their movies like over time
they'll get better at using the technology and the
technology itself will become more seamless just
on a story level thematically totally the movie
does a good job at taking thor to the next logical
stage in his journey like without giving away big
spoils or anything like that don't worry i will
talk about all the really specific things during
the movies plot details and what's happening
with all the characters next in the mcu when we
get to easter egg videos later this week but if
you're a fan of following the character all these
years like you're a fan of the first thor movie
the second thor movie just seeing him evolve over
time they take him to like the next logical stage
and if you've read the comics you have an idea of
where they're taking this character like on a real
cosmic level a simpler way of thinking about it
is the movie is store just kind of coming to terms
with all the trauma that he's experienced and
putting that into context and just figuring out
what it is that he's supposed to be doing with all
of his god tier power like i have all this power
what am i supposed to do with it some of you who
are longtime comic book fans will be like i have
an answer for that i can tell you exactly what he
needs to be doing next because of all these big
story lines that they're setting up don't worry
we'll talk about that later this week after the
movie comes out big reminder to stay through
the credits because there are two post-credit
scenes like most traditional marvel movies like
one of them is a reference back to something
that happened earlier in the film and another
is meant to tease what's happening next with
the story line with the characters please do not
post spoilers for the post credit scenes in the
comments below don't worry i will do full videos
for that later this week after the movie comes out
but if you have any big questions about what's
going on with the characters what's going on with
the movie what's going on with the future of the
marvel cinematic universe just write it below in
the comments and i'll address it during my bonus
videos later this week like i said i've got a
whole bunch of bonus videos for the movie that
i'll start posting on friday when it comes out
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss those speaking of thor we just got our
first look at loki season 2. you can click here
for those scenes and learn what's going on during
those episodes and click here for all my thor love
and thunder videos i'll be sure to update the link
as soon as i start posting my post credit scenes
and full breakdown easter egg videos for the movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!